[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est important pour moi parce que j'ai aussi de
la nourriture
pour aider ma famille parce que ce confinement
est que ces choses ne
vont pas bien vous n'avez pas de nourriture
aussi donc ce recyclage nous aide à
obtenir  au moins un peu de nourriture à mettre
sur la table pour les enfants
[Musique]
donc
ces aiguilles sont chères mais si vous vous
connectez ici
présenter pour les enfants de l'école pour
le déjeuner ils l'apportent à l'école c'est très
bien
nous sommes très heureux  pour obtenir ce projet
[Musique],
nous travaillons donc simplement pour en faire une
partie du mode de vie de la communauté
en développant juste plus de
programmes éducatifs où nous voulons apprendre à la
communauté à prendre ce
matériau recyclable, le transformer en art ou
créer  et recyclez et créez d'autres
choses avec c'est là que nous le vendons sur
le marché
[Musique]
vous